on this episode we talk about pampering
adblocking and politicians and feeling
groovy
and
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 148 of
the askgaryvee show yesterday d-roc
stumbled hard and create an awkward show
so that was fun today we have a packed
house with us including a new gary team
member brittany say hello Brittany comes
from the LA office is her first day on
the team could work closely with Andy
excited and that's what's going on at
Vayner today nice day I'm headed to
London oh I have to do my official Jets
prediction today though there could be
an episode tomorrow where I could do it
there but we're not completely firm yet
that we're gonna do an episode what do
you think safe way to go with the
official prediction in this episode
otherwise then we'd have a blank spot
okay official prediction at the end of
the show India let's get into that what
you're supposed to crescendo with me or
Harmonizers that's not gonna work he
can't fake me up right so let's just do
statements Suzy says I get tons of
emails from politicians begging for
money how would you do better if you ran
for president
hashtag ready for Gary yeah I mean look
guys we've addressed this multiple times
if you're new to the show I will never
run for president cuz I wasn't born in
this country and if I can't have the top
gig I'm not playing the game how would I
do it better easy it's the whole thesis
of all 148 episodes of the show it's all
about depth not with the like nobody's
winning the random I'm gonna blast you
with email give me 20 bucks game buy my
stuff game the the blanketing and hoping
and praying versus the depth is the
complete misunderstanding of how to sell
I think oftentimes it makes sense to me
that politicians are bad at this because
most of my politician friends are
terrible businesspeople and sales people
so it makes sense and usually it you
know it's really it's actually stunning
what kind of level of disrespect I have
for most politicians salesmanship
sell themselves but not other products
and I think that that at some level is
an intriguing aspect and fine line in
this whole thing and so email marketing
is no different than what you know the
Direct Mail that they used to do to try
to get dollars and so I don't know I
mean there's so many ways to do it
better I mean look I think one of the
best things a politician can do is
literally sit in the room sit on our
goddamn ass and for 15 hours take a
phone take a phone and literally do and
literally do you know Twitter reply
videos literally search your name
because everyone's talking and they
either love you or they hate you because
if you're neutral you're in deep crap
and and just reply to them and say no
Rick that is not my policy or think
Susie for the support it's the depth
over the with games so the same stuff
that works and selling stuff selling
anything works in this scenario and so I
think Twitter replies I think would be
disproportionate powerful I think
Facebook is the most important platform
for a politician due to the fact that
older people tend to vote and that I
think that facebook is the holy grail of
45 to 70 year old reach right now even
better than television
so I would I would put out a lot of
content in that world and talk more
about my policies and my thoughts and
more importantly show the human side of
me I don't know if people been paying
attention but I believe the last four to
five presidential elections have been
completely predicated on a popularity
contest and we're in the entertainment
of politics era not to get political but
like if you just look at all of them I
mean like whether you hate Obama or you
hate bush these are likable people to
those sectors in comparison know we're
like complete and what's going on now we
are in the entertainment mode and so I
would be entertaining if I had that
opportunity because that's what would
work and so that's what I would do I
mean cold emailing is doing absolutely
nothing it feels completely cold it you
know I just want to do it Ian s Gary
what's your opinion on incorporating
curse words into your actual brand and
not just the content yeah I think that
I'm look I think if you're gonna go down
a path where you're going to be doing
something that you consciously know that
a lot of people aren't going to like
whether that is cursing whether it is
before-mentioned politics religion
gender issues about you know race there
are pillars in our society that evoke
emotion and have lines in the sand
cursing is one of them a lighter version
and some of the other things I mentioned
but you have the absolute weigh the pros
and the cons of it you will turn off a
stunning percentage of people by over
cursing and there will be a smaller
sector that is super motivated by it for
me it's just very simple cursing for me
is very simple it's just what happens
when I have the camera on me like the
more people that look at me it's what I
do it's very in and so in it's just
entrenched in me and so I believe that I
have to always at all cost be me because
that's my biggest upside if you're
forcing the curse word because you're
targeting 16 to 22 year olds and they
you think they're gonna think it's cool
and it doesn't come from your soul
you're gonna lose but if you're cursing
comes from your soul if you are like if
you are like this is peanut mother
butter like this is it like if that's
where you're going with it then like
cool like if I truly believe that people
have a stunning positive reaction to
disproportional authenticity I am an
absolute byproduct of it I've watched as
my maturity and comfort zone with it has
grown what it's meant to me it allows
people to it's just a nice thing and so
if you're authentically they're cool but
like coming from your soul coming from
your heart not forcing it is the key
regardless of cursing not curse saying
how many people do the other side we
don't talk about the other side you know
I always get talked about being rogue or
aggressive or things that I nature what
about the people that are forcing the
kindness or the [ __ ] like that's
going on way more there's way more
people way more people forcing the
acceptance and and approval and
following the path than our people
that's why the people that are going the
other way have disproportional anomaly
results so how about that question
how about India the people that don't
curse when they feel it
right yeah do it feels good and right
let's go
keep going you really you inspired a
nation it's gonna be huge means Minnie
says Hustle is good but often wears us
down
do you ever pamper yourself like maybe
go in for a pedicure manicure Minnie
Mouse no Minnie hoping nah
Minnie do I ever pamper myself not in
the cliche like I'd bite all my nails my
nails are a disaster now that I've been
working out for 15 months Mike makes me
do massages because I need them at times
and I like it
it's nice good thing no I'm not really
into math with cliche things i pamper
myself by doing whatever I want at all
times always so I would I would call
that the ultimate pampering so that
feels good that's me I think is by the
way that it you know what that would
have been a very interesting moment if
you want to talk about what the best
outcome of being a successful
entrepreneur it's that the money is
really fine
the admiration is fine there's nothing
close than knowing that I could just get
up right now and just like you know sit
like you notice before like I slammed
India's laptop and she's like great you
have no questions not great right what
what do you do about it
India so you know like like I like that
I like I like being able to do what I
want I don't know what that just was if
I want to get up for a second I'm gonna
get up for a second I think the way I
pamper myself is if I do want to if I
want to turn my 40th upcoming birthday
into a family celebration I can afford
to do that that feels incredible and so
a paper myself by the experiences going
to London in a couple of hours to watch
a Jets game that's my pampering doing
the things that make me happy but what
you know I don't get excitement out of a
two-hour pedicure where I unwind and
read gossip but many people do I walk
around New York City and watch it happen
74 thousand times a day so cool awesome
do your thing so you know I don't I
don't you know I'm trying to make my
life a pampering moment it's good stuff
right feeling like you should just like
always do what feels right
it's all good at the moment they're
gonna be like free the people from
Brandon NSF you're doing just fine in
New York do nothing I just feel like
you're doing good hippie stuff here too
yeah he said my EP roots in SF I mean
yeah you you brought it here too Oh Andy
what do you say I brought it with you
okay good I was like just excited that
you said something was honey Andy I like
Andy I like pay Andy's game Andy has got
the game of like he doesn't talk all the
time but when he says something it's
meaningful like I actually that was a
genuine reaction of like what you say
because I actually value the things and
he says cuz he doesn't say them as often
it's not quiet he's not a mute but he
talks with me he talks he talks with her
stuff to be talked about I respect I
really respect that I don't have that
skill I don't India but you can
counteract it with listening well I'm a
tremendous listener this is the big this
is the big unknown about me steam it's
true I never said it wasn't
yeah India this is really starting to
become like the z100 morning zoo like
just full characters everywhere good
brandon asks you don't talk much about
adblocking with more people doing it how
small and medium publishers and blogs
survive they'll survive by adjusting to
the reality of the marketplace there
used to not be ads and they would make
native content and soap operas
integrated their products into the shows
and the Ed Sullivan Show put a big fat
car of Lincoln Towncar that paid for an
entire show in an Alpo or whatever
that's outpost dog food right
Alpo used to bring out it's right we
used to bring out the dog on the Today
Show and eat the goddamn Alpo right in
front of America and so ads my friends
are just one way to monetize I didn't
run ads on Wine Library TV all those
years when everybody told me I decided
to monetize by getting paid millions of
dollars to write a book and to speak and
to actually build an audience and
monetize them differently instead of
making nickels and dimes on them
Nichols knives are cool but you know
which way better $100 bills I feel like
that's them from the movie right I mean
that's what it is though
and so I'm laughing at everybody's panic
because I think lowest common
denominator average players are gonna
get forced into being better actually
this is gonna motivate people to step up
their game and not just mail it in and
so I'm excited to watch smaller and
large you know is way more you know it's
a funny question and shorts coming from
an entrepreneurial place three companies
have a lot more to lose than you like a
block again listen it's all relative
right like your four hundred bucks there
are forty million fine but like
everybody's equal in this everybody's
gonna be disrupted not just small
businesses and small publishers big
publishers that make all their God their
money on banner ads and things of that
nature
have a real issue at hand and I think
it's goddamn great because what I think
is actually happening is that it's
better for the end consumer I mean it is
not fun for me especially now that we're
unfold ripping meat it back
sorry periscope how you guys doing I'm
just showing you dear I'll show you
myself because you don't to look at me
right
and so what they'd rather look at me
it's the askgaryvee show d-roc you know
I forgot my thought cuz I got mad at you
rock you know because got it because I
don't want to go to like espn.com and
check a score and a big fat banner ad
pops up and I got an exit and then I
miss it and then I'm going to something
I don't want and that cost me six
seconds and time is the asset and so I
really really think it's great I'm not
talking about it because I've been
talking about intrusive advertising my
whole life this is just a continuation
it will get Tebow ad blocking whatever
comes next feed blocker like whatever it
is it's all gonna happen
it's all happening in the end what else
Rachel s how does the engagement on
YouTube compare to other social
platforms is the reward worth the effort
absolutely YouTube is like literally one
of the great platforms of the world and
the engagements very high there's tons
of it as a matter of fact I put on my
phone I would take it this time
I just put YouTube finally at the front
of my phone because I'm engaging more in
the comments cuz there's so much going
on there and thank you so much for
everybody's watching the show on YouTube
the engagements super worked out what he
taught who's a loser that's Rachel
don't be sorry end it Rachel come on
what do you mean the engagement have you
not seen a video on YouTube even [ __ ]
videos have like three people saying you
suck I mean they don't even wait for
time to do that on Twitter and get you
it's incredible on YouTube
the common thing is bonkers videos that
do well get tens of thousands of people
saying things there maybe you choose the
best engagement platform on the internet
I mean Rachel by sorry
statement they would love some comments
the interesting I feel like this really
did take the most Radio like vibe cares
to see what people think about that glad
the show went back to its normal self
and and that's it Oh official prediction
official Jets prediction I've been very
hot I mean I had probably like 40 to 60
emails this week of like getting excited
for my official prediction because
people are now gonna bet heavily against
it
so please want to first make note that
this is not official endorsement or any
legal ramifications of you following
this advice she's on your head I don't
know what I gonna get yeah yeah kids are
lawyer official prediction I believe
that the New York Jets will win this
weekend I think the Dolphins are broken
from the head coach down and I feel like
the Jets will win I think ivory will
play this weekend I'm still pretty
worried about Decker and think he will
not play my gut tells me or if he does
it's gonna be very cautious limited but
will say he might play they do have a
bye week off of this so I think a lot of
guys are gonna go and I think they match
up well I like that it's a neutral place
I think London is an international town
let's call it what it is New York is a
better brand than Miami and I think
they'll be a little bit of love for that
and so I think that the Jets go into
Wembley where I will be super excited
and pull this game out 19:14 think we
tight I don't think there's made a lot
of scoring
unless there's turnovers the way my
prediction gets off is too many
turnovers and scoring which could happen
though tannenhill like threw a lot of
interceptions last weekend not not usual
for him 1914 New York Jets you keep
asking questions
I'll
keep answering them when it feels good